Last week you answered a couple questions for me regarding electrically recharging depleted
cells.
So, if we missed last week, we were talking about your cell membranes hold a charge that
charges measurable, actually.
That's called your phase angle to measure your, you can measure your phase angle.
For those who, you know, days go by, Mr. Come in our office who used to measure your phase
angle, you mentioned the PEMF was good technology to assist with this.
I have a beaver, a beaver is a PEMF machine, so that I have been using twice per day,
more than an evening.
I've found two interviews on your blog library referencing the beaver and your guests
categorize it into the category of PEMF.
That's right, because the beaver is a post-electromagnetic field.
It's called a low-gouse post-electromagnetic field machine.
I doctor recommended it to improve micro-circulation, but does beaver also work to electrically
recharge depleted low voltage cells?
The answer is yes, that's exactly what the beaver does, that's exactly what a PEMF machine
does, that's really the benefit, made benefit of a PEMF machine.
That's really the benefit, made benefit of a PEMF machine, made benefit of a PEMF machine, made benefit of a PEMF machine.